[Musique]
nous sommes le 2 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités l'émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vient de lancer la plateforme rail
prédisait le site a pour but d'informer
sur la chlamydia c'est une infection
sexuellement transmissible les
explications de l'épidémiologiste en
charge de cette ce dispositif dans l
édition d'hier vous avez découvert la
première édition justement du festival
féminin pluriel qui se tiendra du 20
février au 1er avril dans les yvelines
ce soir vous entendrez son parrain l'un
des parrains c'est le comédien yvelinois
sam karmann après ishare mais il en
place par le pôle santé de l'ue vs qu
voici l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
plate-forme high predict lancé le mois
dernier le site a pour but d'informer et
sur la chlamydia c'est une infection
sexuellement transmissible qui touche
près de 10% des jeunes femmes entre 18
et 25 ans vous pouvez aussi lutter
contre cette infection participants à
cette étude
vous serez suivi durant deux ans
elisabeth de laroque castano
épidémiologistes nous explique aye
predict le dispositif c'est une
interview signée haussmann vendeurs d
avec julie barrantes bonjour bonjour
alors dites moi pourquoi avoir mis en
place l predict vous êtes parti de
quelques postulats alors nous sommes
partis du postulat que donc il prédit
que s'intéresse aux infections à
chlamydia trachomatis chez les jeunes
femmes et on est parti du constat que
est bien celle infections sexuellement
transmissibles la plus fréquente chez
les jeunes femmes de 18 à 25 ans et que
on a besoin de travailler sur les
recommandations de dépistage de cette
infection
pourquoi parce que c'est une infection
qui le plus souvent ne donne pas de
symptômes mais qui par contre
peut se compliquer immédiatement ou
ultérieurement dans la vie immédiatement
cette infection qui au départ ne parle
pas beaucoup peut se compliquer
d'infection qui sont un petit peu plus
haut dans l'appareil génital comme les
salpingite qui sont frottés terme déjà
entendu par les jeunes femmes pour voilà
donc ça ça peut être des complications
immédiates et puis à long terme lorsque
les jeunes femmes sont désir d'enfant et
bien il peut y avoir des grossesses
extra-utérines qui sont liés à cette
infection
anciennement contracter ou
éventuellement aussi des troubles de la
fertilité donc lorsqu'elles sont en
désir d'enfant et qu'elles ont fait les
infections à chlamydia trachomatis et
bien il peut y avoir un problème j'étais
seul et de conception alors par rapport
à et predict dites-moi ce qu'on peut
retrouver dessus sur cette plateforme
alors lorsque on va chercher si on veut
chercher de l'information sur rail
predict et bien il ya de l'information
sur le site internet de l'université
nous avons également de l'information
qui est bien sûr délivré par ailleurs il
faut rappeler qu'à y predict existe et
est à commencer par sky cher existe
ishare c'est la grande étude sur la
santé des étudiants qui existe depuis
2000 13 portés par les universités de
bordeaux et l'université de versailles
saint quentin et donc dans laquelle est
bien l'objectif c'est d'avoir trente
mille étudiants qui participent qui sont
suivis pendant dix ans et on s'intéresse
à ses étudiants sur différentes
thématiques de santé high predict existe
parce que ishare existe donc dans el
cheikh la préoccupation que nous avions
au moment où cette étude a été
monter c'est également une préoccupation
autour des infections sexuellement
transmissibles chez les jeunes et en
particulier du coup chez les jeunes
étudiants alors c'est qui peut
s'inscrire
c'était toujours pour continuer
là-dessus parce que ce que je
vous voulez dire sur cette étude c'est
qu'il ya un grand rôle d'internet c'est
à dire qu'après une fois que tout ça
c'est fait la grande partie de la
participation c'est répondre à des
questionnaires internet tous les six
mois et faire un auto prélèvements qu'on
envoie par la poste donc les contraintes
sont relativement veut dire est modérée
et puis à la fin et bien il y à une
consultation de gynécologie dans les
centres hospitalo universitaires qui
sont associés à notre projet il faut
savoir juste aussi qu' on s'est associé
avec tous ces services de gynécologie
qui participe au groupe de recherche et
qui sont complètement danse danse est
dans cette aventure
bien sûr et donc quelles sont les
contraintes d'inscription il peut
s'inscrire
alors qui peut s'inscrire pardon et bien
en fait c'est assez simple un tout jeune
fille inscrits dans une université
participantes ishare eh bien peut se
présenter ayant entre 18 et 25 ans peut
se présentait donc dans un des services
de médecine préventive universitaire et
à ce moment là il ya un certain nombre
d'autres vérifications de critères
d'inclusion très simple après discussion
avec la chargée de recherche clinique en
charge de l'étude
il faut que cette jeune fille du coup
participe également à el cheikh il est
évidemment pas obligé qu'elle y
participe déjà c'est à dire qu'à
l'occasion de cette demande
d'information
de l'envi de participer à et predict et
bien le peut aussi s'inscrire à l'étude
ishare et à l'issue de cette étude que
c'est une possibilité de mettre en avant
voilà ce souci avec déclamer les
chlamydias pour que les autorités se
bouger un petit peu plus derrière
alors bien sûr tout ça se fait dans un
contexte où ça fait déjà quelques années
que les autorités de santé se pose la
question de savoir s'il faut revoir ses
recommandations ces recommandations
elles sont anciennes et beaucoup
d'éléments porte à croire qu'il faut les
revoir
pourquoi parce qu'on a aussi observé que
probablement on a des arguments pour
dire que le nombre d'infections
sexuellement transmissibles à chlamydia
pourrait avoir augmenté sur cette
dernière décennie peut-être un
relâchement des méthodes de prévention 1
chez les jeunes femmes et les jeunes
hommes d'autres raisons donc il ya ce
contexte il ya un contexte aussi de
développement de nouvelles techniques de
prélèvement qui rendent du coup le
dépistage beaucoup plus acceptable pour
les jeunes femmes et donc il ya déjà des
réflexions de la part de groupes
constitués par deux constituées par les
autorités de santé pardon pour réfléchir
aux recommandations de dépistage donc
tout ça se fait dans ce contexte là ça
n'est pas détaché et bien sûr du conte
du contexte dans ce domaine le domaine
du dépistage des infections sexuellement
transmissibles
donc les résultats d'une telle étude
bien sûr et c'est ça l'idée
c'est qu'ils puissent être utilisés pour
que les experts qui se réunissent pour
élaborer ses recommandations puissent
avoir des données
en plus des données qui leur permettent
de réfléchir à l'élaboration de ces
recommandations
alors ce ne sont pas les seules données
bien sûr un qui vont intervenir mais
c'est extrêmement important pour savoir
qu'en europe
bien sûr d'autres pays ont réfléchi ou
continue à réfléchir là dessus il ya eu
une première étude ya quelques années
cas pas forcément permis de conclure et
notre étude et les résultats de notre
étude sont attendus par différents pays
avec lesquels on travaille en europe sur
ce sujet là et bien je vous remercie
merci un mot de culture à présent nous
en parlions déjà hier la première
édition du festival féminin pluriel qui
se tiendra du 20 février au 1er avril
dans les yvelines après avoir écouté
sabine caussens et la co présidente du
festival directrice du prisme salle de
spectacle à elancourt je vous propose
d'écouter à présent le par un lent
départ de cette édition s et sam karmann
comédien de théâtre mais aussi acteur il
était au micro de camille lambert et
nous sommes toujours à la maison elsa
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pour le
lancement du festival féminin pluriel et
cette fois ci nous sommes en compagnie
de sam karmann qui est parrain de cette
première édition
c'est à dire que quand on est artiste on
se pose pas la question que je travaille
avec des artistes je ma première
réaction c'est pas de me dire que c'est
une femme
ou c'est un homme est ce que c'est une
actrice - acteur est ce que c'est une
autre issue ou un autre metteur en scène
metteur en scène non mais je m'aperçois
en fait que quand on m'a alerte sur le
sur le problème car son état on
s'aperçoit que les femmes doivent se
battre beaucoup plus fort pour pouvoir
avoir les des postes supprimés de
responsabilité dans tous les métiers la
culture pas seulement les artistes pas
seulement les actrices bien sûr et
metteur en scène et des auteurs même si
c'est intéressant de 2,2 qu'elle ne se
censure pas qu'elle ose écrire pour les
formes théâtrales ou pour le cinéma pour
la télévision et scénariste de plus en
plus de femmes dans les postes de
responsabilité celle qui vraiment dirige
bas s'aperçoit que voilà son moi il y en
a beaucoup moins voilà donc les chiffres
sont assez violent même quand on se dit
que jusqu'à jusqu'à la maîtrise
il ya plus de femmes que d'hommes qui
ont des maîtrises à partir dans la
maîtrise et tout ce qui dépasse et à
dire vraiment parler les grands postes
d'encadrement ya plus de femmes ça
s'effondre comme si elle sait elle
disparaissait quoi vous c'est quelque
chose que vous voulez un petit peu
dénoncé m en maître mettre en lumière
par ce festival où c'est à dire non
ma culture à moi si je suis extrêmement
féministe je sais pas sans doute la
façon dont j'ai été éduqué et donc ça
m'a toujours semblé normal mais c'est
quand on m'a dit qu'on attire mon
attention quand je vois par exemple même
politiquement que le droit des femmes en
matière de en matière de contraceptifs
qu'on peut remettre en cause que ce soit
en pologne où que ce soit des mouvements
qui descendent dans la rue
décédé vie rouler sur moi je me dis mais
oui mais donc donc ce que je pensais
être une chose naturelle où la parité
c'était légalité de l'égalité a mené à
la parité
non c'est dans les textes c'est dans les
lois mais les lois n'étant pas
contraignante
voilà donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un
numéro splosion peut-être pas aller
jusque là mais en tous les cas être
vigilant et quand une initiative comme
celle ci c'est à dire festival de
théâtre féminin pluriel quand sabine
caussens que je connais bien pour
l'action qu'il a menée pendant de
longues années au prisme d'elancourt
avec d'une programmation formidable m'a
sollicité
voilà je répondu présent et vous le
disiez justement ces lois ne sont pas
contraignantes est ce que du coup la
place de l'artiste aussi c'est de
transmettre un petit peu ce message
votre place à vous c'est d'en parler
l'artiste est par définition il ya ces
formidables le métier d'artiste parce
qu'on est libre on ne doit rien à
personne même si c'est une liberté
illusoire
parce que les propos porte je prends je
prends ma place de citoyen de citoyens
artistes dans la cité ont ré je pense
profondément que c'est par la culture
qu'on arrive à changer les mentalités et
que c'est par la culture qu'on a
peut-être plus de levier pour que cette
égalité homme-femme cette parité cesse
d'être un voeu pieux et qu'on n'est même
plus à se battre pour ça que ça soit
tellement évident que mais encore du
chemin
l'idée de ce festival aussi c'est de ne
plus exister au final c'est un festival
qui se veut éphémère quelque part voilà
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est un
éphémère qui s'y risquent de durer
quand on voit justement que année après
année le les femmes doivent toujours se
battre plus en tant que femme simplement
pour être à égalité c'est quand même et
justement alors on parle beaucoup
d'économie de santé notamment avec
olivier vous en avait parlé à l'instant
mais c'est vrai que la culture n'est pas
épargnée également c'est vraiment un
domaine où les femmes n'ont pas toujours
la place qu'elle mériterait peut-être
d'avoir juste oui je pense quand on sait
que par exemple chez les auteurs femme
de roman il y en a beaucoup beaucoup qui
n'ose pas écrire pour le théâtre bon
alors il ya aussi ce qu'il faut les
encourager mais il faut qu'elle se fasse
confiance aussi quoi voilà c'est ça
travaille ça travail collectif à faire
tous ensemble un petit mot parce que
vous avez cités simone de beauvoir et
non pendant la conférence de presse mais
également dans le communiqué de presse
c'est une femme inspirante
ah oui même aujourd'hui encore au 21e
siècle en 2017 ses propos restent
toujours d'actualité
oui oui tout à fait bah oui deuxième
sexe ça on peut on le relit faut le
relire il faut faut le faire lire mais
pas seulement aux femmes aux hommes
surtout arrêtez moi si je me trompe mais
vous avez tourné dans 52 films c'est ça
à peu près à priori et mais seulement
quatre femmes réalisatrices
ça illustre aussi peut-être un peu ce
manque de parité
voila voila vous faites la preuve là
vous avez tout mélanger
quatre femmes c'est pas beaucoup je me
réjouis cette année parce que par
exemple j'ai encore vu hier soir pour
les césar j'ai vu qu'il y avait sur 7
finaliste meilleur film meilleur
réalisateur il y avait trois femmes les
magnifique film de nicole garcia qui
avait une chance de travailler sur mal
de pierres le phénomène divine qui est
un feeling incroyable et j'ai vu hier
soir que je n'avais pas vu mes danseuses
qui est un premier film extraordinaire
je suis passé à côté
quand il est sorti en salles mais là
quelle chance ben voilà c'est le son des
femmes des des premiers films pour deux
d'entre elles et qui sont déjà dans la
catégorie des meilleur film et meilleur
réalisateur c'est voilà voilà deux
femmes qui vont faire parler d'elle donc
plutôt de bonne augure pour la suite on
les a
il n'y a pas que des mauvaises choses
merci beaucoup sam karmann merci encore
la 3d c'est la fin de cette édition du 7
8 les invités on se retrouve lundi avec
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité des
yvelines
[Musique]